Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies
and germs, this is Tim Ferriss, and welcome
to another episode of The Tim Ferriss Show,
where it is my job to deconstruct world-class
performers from all different disciplines.
My guest today is Shirley A. Sahrmann, PT,
PhD.
But before we get to her bio, let me just
explain: Shirley is a legend in the physical
therapy world.
She has influenced some of the top performance
coaches in the world.
She’s also 85 years old, going on 86, and
is not only razor-sharp mentally but in excellent
shape physically.
So she walks the walk.
So let me get to the bio, and I will also
give you a bit of 101 on some of the terms
that we’ll use in the conversation.
Shirley A. Sahrmann, PT, PhD, is Professor
Emerita of Physical Therapy at Washington
University School of Medicine in St. Louis,
Missouri.
She received her bachelor’s degree in physical
therapy and her masters and doctorate degrees
in neurobiology from Washington University,
where she joined the physical therapy faculty
and became the first director of their PhD
program in movement science.
Shirley—and she asked me to call her Shirley—became
a Catherine Worthingham Fellow of the American
Physical Therapy Association in 1986 and in
1998 was selected to receive the Mary McMillan
Award, the Association’s highest honor.
She has also received Washington University’s
Distinguished Faculty Award, the Distinguished
Alumni Award, the School of Medicine’s Inaugural
Distinguished Clinician Award, and an honorary
doctorate from the University of Indianapolis.
She has received, as well, the Bowling-Erhard
Orthopedic Clinical Practice Award from the
Orthopaedic Academy of the APTA.
She has served on the APTA Board of Directors
and as president of the Missouri Chapter.
Her books are iconic.
They have been the initial domino that has
toppled over, so to speak, the enthusiasm,
the ignition, for many people to get into
the field of movement science and physical
therapy and performance coaching.
Her first book, Diagnosis and Treatment of
Movement Impairment Syndromes—you may have
heard Eric Cressey mention this; it was a
hugely influential book for him—has been
translated into seven languages.
Her second book, Movement System Impairment
Syndromes of the Cervical and Thoracic Spines
and the Extremities, has been equally influential
in promoting movement diagnoses.
And in this episode, we do a deep dive on
low-back pain, and that is something for the
first time really I have been struggling with
for the last, let’s just call it nine months
or so.
Could be a bit longer.
And we do get into the weeds with regard to
anatomy, particularly as it relates to the
back stuff that I mentioned.
So I’d like to go over a few terms before
we start the interview so you don’t have
to wonder what they are and feel like you
need to pause to look them up.
You can get through the interview without
listening to my definitions, but some of them
might be helpful.
Also, if you’re a kinesiologist or professional,
please excuse these very simplistic and possibly
slightly off definitions, but they’ll help
a lot of people.
So the first one is the iliac crest.
What is that?
That’s the uppermost border of your pelvic
girdle.
So you can think of the pelvic girdle as that
large boney bowl that you see in the middle
of a skeleton hanging in a science classroom
or something.
You can feel your iliac crest if you press
your thumb into the top of your hip.
That sort of boney ridge is your iliac crest.
The tensor fasciae latae— And I’ve heard
many different pronunciations of this, and
the fact of the matter is no one really speaks
Latin correctly because we don’t know if
it was, you know, veni, vidi, vici, or weni,
widi, wici, for those who get that reference—I
came, I saw, I conquered.
So anyway, it is better known and abbreviated
as the TFL for a lot of people.
So the TFL is a muscle at the outside, very
outside, portion of the thigh, at the very
top.
So you can think of it all— So people think
of it as a hip muscle sometimes.
You use it to balance your pelvis when standing,
walking, or running.
If you ever give someone a piggyback ride,
and a muscle gets super sore on the side of
your hip, that is probably, at least including,
the TFL.
You also use the TFL for abducting your hip
or pulling it away from the midline of your
body, compared to adducting, with two d’s,
which would be pulling it toward the midline.
One way that I remember that—abduction is
like an alien abduction, taking you away,
so moving the, say, leg away from the body,
abducting; bringing the thigh in, adduction,
so like an adductor machine at a gym, one
of those Suzanne Somers thighmaster-type machines
at the gym would be that.
We also talk about muscles that assist in
lateral rotation.
Lateral rotation is rotating away from the
center of the body.
Medial rotation is rotating towards the center.
So imagine if you turned your feet outwards
to look like you’re duck-footed, that would
be lateral rotation.
Out to the sides.
And then if you turn them inward to be pigeon-toed,
that would be medial rotation of both femurs
inward.
All right, psoas major I also mention psoas
major.
That’s spelled P-S-O-A-S major.
That is a large muscle that joins the upper
and lower parts of the body.
And it also contributes to a lot of lower-back
pain.
It connects to the inside of the lower back.
And if you were to take, say, your four fingers,
and move them four inches to either side of
your navel and then press in, say, four inches,
that would probably touch your psoas major,
which is why massage therapy that addresses
it can be so uncomfortable.
For you chefs out there or hunters or people
who might recognize this, this would be the
equivalent of your tenderloin.
So if you’re wondering what a tenderloin
is, it is this muscle in many animals.
There may be other ways to use that butchering
term, but psoas major/tenderloin.
There you have it, used mostly for posture
and so on.
We also get into stenosis as it relates to
my spine.
So stenosis is an abnormal narrowing.
And I have some stenosis around L4, L5, which
is in the lumbar spine, or lower spine, which
puts pressure on some nerves there and causes
all sorts of pain.
The thoracic spine is more of, say, the middle
of the back, and you just think between the
shoulder blades for simplicity.
OK, last, and I could say not least, but who
knows.
These are all kind of equivalent and useful.
You have supine vs. prone positions.
Supine is lying on your back.
Prone is lying on your stomach.
If you’ve ever wondered what a supinated
grip is or a pronated grip, supinated is palm
up.
And you can remember that because if you want
to pour soup into your hand, you have your
palm up.
OK, so that is supine.
And honestly, learning the basics of anatomy
and the basics of some medical terminology
is, I think, one of the best, absolute best,
investments you can make in your health.
Because then you can talk the talk with professionals,
and they take you more seriously, they give
you better advice, they give you the straight
scoop.
So this is all a very good investment of time.
You can find a glossary of these terms and
more in the show notes for this episode at
tim.blog.
And I do want to mention one other thing.
If you want an incredible rotating view of
different muscles like the QL—we talk about
the quadratus lumborum; that’s sort of this
squarish, rectangular muscle in the lower-back
area that is sort of the Grand Central Station
of all sorts of things—if you want to see
anything—the psoas major—check out the
Essential Anatomy 5 app for iOS and Android,
and you can see all of this.
You can also see the circulatory system and
all sorts of other things.
It’s a great app.
Really enjoyed it.
And there are short YouTube tutorials that
I recommend taking a look at if you end up
downloading it.
And that was referred to me by professional
drummer Dave Elitch, who helps people improve
their mechanics, technique, and much more.
And there you have it.
So if you want a video to go with this, I
did record video of this conversation, and
I get up and walk around, and she does an
assessment with me live.
You can go to my YouTube channel, YouTube.com/TimFerriss—two
r’s, two s’s—and that will have some
helpful graphics and so on overlaid into the
video.
OK that’s quite a bit, guys, but I think
it is a helpful prelude.
And now, without further ado, please enjoy
this wide-ranging conversation with Dr. Shirley
Sahrmann.
***
Tim Ferriss: Dr. Sahrmann, Shirley, welcome
to the show.
It's so nice to have you with me today, and
I can't wait to ask a whole host of different
questions, so thank you for making the time.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: My pleasure.
Tim Ferriss: I'd like to begin, perhaps, with
the connective tissue that led to you being
on the show today, which is a friend of mine
and a well-known, I suppose, the label "performance
coach" could be applied, he also has a background
in physical therapy, Eric Cressey.
He works with many major league baseball players,
has a high degree of success with pitchers
specifically, but he has written.
He also mentioned to me that "Diagnosis and
Treatment of Movement Impairment Syndromes
is probably the book…"
and I'm quoting him here, "...is probably
the book that has influenced me more than
any other in my career.
It's worth every penny."
I'm curious why it is that this book seems
to have been so revolutionary for him and
many others.
What would you say explains that or differentiates
that book?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, I think the one
big objective in it — I've actually been
a physical therapist for over 60 years.
During all of that time I've been through
different eras of changes in physical therapy.
Where I've sort of gotten to is how movement
basically induces pathology.
Part of that, trying to explain that and how
it works, is also developing diagnostic categories
that direct physical therapy treatment.
What this book was about was a first attempt
to really put together diagnostic categories
that are based on movement and movement as
an inducer of musculoskeletal problems.
Also, kind of working on the background of
what are the tissue adaptations that contribute
to this?
It really was an organizational attempt to
identify for — the first book covered the
back and the shoulder and the hip, so I guess
the shoulder is one of the things that he
must have been particularly interested in
if he's dealing with pitchers.
The shoulder's really quite complex because
you've got that shoulder blade, as well as
the glenohumeral joint, and it's not as easy
as muscles just turn on or turn off appropriately.
They've got to really be well coordinated.
I think that putting together this kind of
information in a way that could be understood
by a whole variety of people — in fact,
I was so slow in getting it out that I was
grateful that there was the internet and Amazon
selling things, because if it would've only
been sold in medical bookstores, no one like
Eric would've ever found it.
That was one of the advantages of being a
slow writer.
Of course I learned more while all of that
was happening, too.
Tim Ferriss: How did that attempt, or maybe
not attempt, how did that organizational approach
—
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: No, it was an attempt.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, and also the maybe reframing
of movement in the way that you just described,
differ from what came before or what was predominant
at the time?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, to be perfectly
honest with you, Tim, it's not like this insight
has been taken over by even the large majority
of the people in my profession.
It's still a bit of a struggle to have people
move in this direction for a whole variety
of reasons.
Typically, even though I wasn't there when
physical therapy was first started, I wasn't
too far behind.
Typically, the role of the physical therapist
was the doctor figured out what the problem
was, made the diagnosis, and the physical
therapist really provided treatment for what
I think could fairly be called the symptoms
or the consequences of that problem.
In fact, I am old enough that I actually saw
polio patients.
The vaccine had just come out about when I
was entering physical therapy school, so we
had a role in providing the therapy for the
doctor's identified condition.
That's very different than what I'm proposing,
or have proposed with this book.
I think what's beginning to be recognized.
I think the other thing that's so important
about all this, I'm sure you are a reflection
of this, is in the old days, no one thought
lifestyle had anything to do with your health.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I always like to point
out this story.
My family cooked with so much Crisco I don't
know how my blood flows.
If the green beans were too healthy, we had
bacon grease to put on them.
I was very fortunate.
I worked with a physician for a while who
was really leading the way in showing about
the role of exercise and nutrition in — he
did what that's really called translational
research, showing the cellular changes in
animals, and then also running studies in
older people.
It was like an amazing insight for me to realize
that your lifestyle had something to do with
it.
I think that's behind what's slowly emerging
as seeing movement play a different role.
I think what I'd like to get across to people,
it's not inevitable what's going to happen
to you, that you can do things via lifestyle
to improve what your outcome's going to be.
Tim Ferriss: I would love to come back to,
I believe, and I don't want to misquote you,
but something you said which is, "The treatment
of symptoms.
So many offices are treating symptoms, perhaps
not root causes."
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I have read, and you can't believe
everything you read on the internet, so please
correct me if I that's wrong, but that you've
—
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Is that a new saying?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Wow.
Tim Ferriss: That you've described low back
pain as not a diagnosis, but a symptom.
Could you just speak to that?
Because as someone who currently for the last
maybe six to nine months has had a very perplexing
constellation of symptoms that I describe
as low back pain, this I think will resonate
with many people who are listening.
Would you mind elaborating on low back pain
as a symptom and not a diagnosis?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, I mean, just what
you're saying, you're saying it's low back
pain.
You're just telling me that you've got pain
and you're telling me where you've got pain.
That is clearly a symptom.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, right.
I am from Long Island, so sometimes I ask
the silliest of questions, but got to start
with the basics.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
There you go.
Well, the nice part is you can actually get
reimbursed for making that big, clever diagnosis.
Even without an MD degree.
No.
Where I would be looking at that problem,
and I have an idea of what your problem is
—
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Okay.
Already.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, just because — we
can talk about that.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I don't want to sound
too glib about it, but so what I would be
doing is naming your low back pain by the
movement that most consistently causes your
symptoms, by changing that movement, reduces
or eliminates your symptoms.
Then I'm talking to you about a real cause
of the problem.
Now, it's not going down to the tissue level
and saying, "Well, it's a disc or a facet
joint," or any of the rest of it.
Here, again, in some ways when you have a
problem like that, you can't say in the back
that one tissue's at fault, because a lot
of tissues have to change if you're having
pain coming from your back region.
The expertise of a physical therapist needs
to be, what is the movement that's either
causing or exacerbating that problem?
Tim Ferriss: I'm curious to — well, maybe
we can dive into, you said that you thought
you might know what my issue is.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
That's because I know you're a big exerciser.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Yes, indeed.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I mean, do you want
me to just give you a ballpark idea?
Tim Ferriss: I do, absolutely.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Okay.
Well, because would you believe that abdominals
can get to be too much overdeveloped?
Tim Ferriss: It makes some intuitive sense,
but it's not something you hear many people
talk about.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I know, I know, I know.
Even within the community of physical therapists,
people are really exercising big time.
I mean, high-intensity exercise is super popular.
I'm all for it because it'll increase our
patient load.
One of the things that happens when your abdominals
are overdeveloped, because what happens when
muscles hypertrophy, they become stiffer,
and muscles are like springs.
They have — I mean, I'm using the mechanical
word of stiffness.
When the abdominals get to be too much, they
increase the compression on your spine.
The way you can check me out on this is if
you look to see if you take a deep breath,
if you go from maximum exhalation to maximum
inhalation, you should be able to change the
circumference of your rib cage about two and
a half to three inches.
If you can't really do that, then it means
that the stiffness of your abdominal muscles
is so much it's adding to the compression.
Then, if you have any kind of asymmetry, for
example, if you put your hands on your iliac
crest, and one iliac crest is slightly higher
than the other, then basically your spine
is in a side bend.
If it's in a side bend, and you're squeezing
on your vertebrae, they're not happy because
they aren't lined up as optimally as possible.
Do you see what I mean?
Tim Ferriss: I do, absolutely.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Okay.
That's the ballpark idea.
That also reflects how we're looking at these
problems.
What is it about the way you move?
What is it about the way you've exercised
or done things that cause the symptoms?
Tim Ferriss: I would love to spend more time
on this, selfishly of course, because the
reason I am sitting and not standing for this
interview is because of this lower back pain,
which is actually —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: So it's worse when you're
standing than when you're sitting?
Tim Ferriss: It is worse when I am standing.
Now, I do have — I guess what — we can
jump right into the weeds.
I have a transitional segment, if I'm using
the right terminology, in my lumbar, so I
do have quite a bit of excessive lower back
sway or atypical lower back sway, just for
people listening.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Now, when you say sway,
do you mean an increased curve?
Tim Ferriss: Increased curve, yeah, like lordosis
and kind of guts hanging out, and with that
anterior pelvic tilt, right?
Standing and slow walking, say walking through
a museum, tend to aggravate it the most.
My brother has the same thing, although in
the last six months or so when I sit on a
very hard surface, like a hard bench or something
like that, it also causes this pain.
I have had imaging, but maybe we could talk
about imaging, how you see some people who
look like they've gone through a mulcher on
their back MRI, but they're asymptomatic,
and then you have the other.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
Right.
That's the whole point.
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
Then you have the opposite.
I do have some stenosis around L4, L5, but
the pain feels to be localized around the
SI joint.
The relief, if this is helpful, I know we're
getting a little technical for some folks,
but the relief that I've had in the last week
was actually from seeing a chiropractor.
There's a high degree of variability with
chiropractors, but he works with a lot of
athletes.
He put me on a machine that provided some
traction.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: There's traction.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
He said, "I think it's actually that you may
have a disc pressing on a nerve that runs
past the SI joint, so you're misattributing
the cause to the SI."
I've had quite a bit of relief, but to answer
your question, standing, slow walking combined
with standing, like going through a museum
or a cocktail party, sitting on hard surfaces,
those are the three things that hurt.
Brisk walking does not hurt.
Actually that type of, this is a primitive
interpretation, but sort of repeated stretching
of the hip flexors, if I'm getting enough
terminal hip extension, feels really good
to the back.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yep.
Yep.
Tim Ferriss: Those are a few of the things.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Have you put your hands
on your pelvis to see when you're walking
if it rotates?
Tim Ferriss: I have not.
I would love to know how to do that properly.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, I mean, it's not
rocket science.
You know where your pelvis, you know where
your hands are.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Just because very often
when your hip flexors are not even just not
short, just stiff, stiffer than your back
as you walk, it rotates your pelvis.
That's where you're going to be getting your
symptoms from.
Evidently when you go fast enough, you're
not staying static and you're causing enough
equal movement.
That would be the big thing.
When you stand up and you're in this anterior
tilt, can you contract your abdominals enough
to get out of the tilt?
Tim Ferriss: I can, yeah.
It seems as though I can.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Does that decrease your
symptoms?
Tim Ferriss: It does decrease my symptoms.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Right.
Tim Ferriss: If my back is bothering me, I'll
very often do basically a forward fold or
a full squat and then round my back and get
into that flexed position.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: The flexed position and even
mild extension does not bother the back.
If I do a compression test, like a heel drop
test or I pull myself into a chair, it's standing
straight up that, and with compression, that
shows that type of intolerance.
I get that pain kind of directly on the lower
spine.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: The other thing to try,
Tim, is when you stand up, put your feet apart.
Separate them out and see if that changes
your symptoms.
Tim Ferriss: And what is that doing?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, number one is
this little thing I referred to before.
If one iliac crest is higher than another,
and it's a test for what we call relative
stiffness.
If you are — one of the big hip flexor that's
problematic is called the tensor fasciae latae.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: It's an abductor.
If you put your feet apart, so your hips are
abducted, it takes the stretch off of that
band.
Any kind of asymmetry that you would have,
particularly with the transition vertebrae,
would be playing into the symptoms.
Do you see what I mean?
Tim Ferriss: I do.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: You could find out,
yeah, and then if you put them together and
your symptoms increased, then you would know
that that's what's playing a role, doing this.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I'll add a few more things just because this
is a rare opportunity to get to talk with
you about this.
My TFL is very — tends to be very tight
and sensitive.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: That’s right.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: The piriformis muscle is also
very tight.
A piece of this that may be helpful as far
as, may or may not be helpful, but what gives
my back also some release is working on the,
very specifically, the iliacus and then some
of the adductors on the inside of the thigh.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
[inaudible].
Tell me what that means.
Tim Ferriss: Well, having someone really dig
into the abdomen to have me, say, extend the
leg almost.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Okay.
It's not you working on it.
Somebody else is working on it.
Tim Ferriss: No, it's somebody else working
on it.
Then, it's not very pleasant for people who
are listening.
Then some of my adductors, I don't know if
it's magnus, longus, or whatever, but also
very tight and seemingly potentially weak.
To come back to the height, maybe the asymmetry
of the iliac crest, my right side seems to
get hiked up a lot.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Doing wall sits to try to press
them maybe back into some symmetry seems to
alleviate some of the symptoms as well.
I don't know if any of this makes any sense,
but —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: See, that's what I mean.
You've just confirmed — one of my thoughts
is that if your right iliac crest is higher
than your left — but then I would also bet
that your right TFL is stiffer than your left.
If that's playing a role, then when you put
your feet apart, your iliac crest should level
out and that should help with your symptoms.
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
Historically when I've been recording podcasts,
I basically end up in that really wide stance.
I think I'm — now, is that — I mean, that's
useful for maybe temporarily relieving the
symptoms if I'm recording a podcast.
In terms of corrective measures, let's just
say using your —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Have you ever tried
anything where you're in the quadruped position?
Tim Ferriss: I have, actually.
A long time ago I did a lot of movement in
quadruped position, but I would be curious
to hear what you have in mind.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, because part of
what happens when one iliac crest stays higher
than another, and I'm not — to be perfectly
honest with you, I haven't quite figured it
all out yet, but there's some adaptation of
the other hip muscles.
I've just found that if you do this in quadruped,
you just rock back, often it will improve
the asymmetry that you have.
Tim Ferriss: Basically being on hands and
knees?
So, your knees —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Hands and knees, right.
Let your hips drop to about 90 degrees.
You don't have to go back all the way.
You just need to go back a little bit.
Go back by easily pushing with your hands,
because otherwise if you activate your hip
flexors, it could pull it, contribute to your
problems.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Okay.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Then, can you tolerate
prone face down?
Tim Ferriss: I can, yeah.
Yeah, I can tolerate prone.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And then you need to
just do — just flex your knee, and then
you need to laterally rotate your hips.
You're letting your knee flex to 90 degrees
and then let your foot go in towards the other
leg.
That's lateral rotation.
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: That kind of motion
will help to elongate the TFL.
ITB.
Tim Ferriss: Interesting.
And you're doing that leg by leg?
The [inaudible].
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Oh, yeah.
One leg at a time.
Tim Ferriss: One leg at a time.
Okay.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Do everything bilaterally,
yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Very interesting.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: You can try those things.
Let me know.
Tim Ferriss: Great.
I will.
I will do both of those.
If we zoom out just for a moment — thank
you for that, by the way.
We may come back to it.
How would you describe the movement systems
syndromes approach?
So, the MSS approach.
What would the sort of lay description of
that be?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: It basically is putting
a formal name — in 2013, the American Physical
Therapy Association adopted the movement system
as its identity.
To me what's really important about all of
this is that it's a way of trying to say to
the public that there is a body system called
the movement system.
It's not like the traditional anatomically
defined systems, like the cardiovascular system
or the musculoskeletal system or the nervous
system.
It's a system of systems, but that's just
like, in my mind, the immune system, which
nothing is more important in medicine these
days than the immune system.
It's a system of systems.
It uses many of the different organs in its
function.
Metabolic system is the same way.
When you think of it as running from subcellular
all the way up to how do you move in your
environment, movement is critical.
The movement stops, everything stops.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I think we take — in
some ways, to me, it's like a parallel to
the nutrition system because we take for granted
doing it.
Yet, there's right ways and there are wrong
ways.
The whole idea of this is to realize that
their movement does involve a system.
Just like we were talking about before, movement
— if you have a lesion in a system, like
you have rheumatoid arthritis or something,
or you have a stroke, then you've got pathology
in your movement.
As I indicated, movement can also induce pathology.
In fact, we know if people don't move enough,
they develop the metabolic system syndrome
and other kinds of things because for lack
of movement.
How important it is to move, this is related
to the lifestyle issue and doing it right.
One of the things I always loved doing with
patients was saying, "So, who taught you to
walk?"
They say "Nobody."
I say, "That's the problem."
Just because you're doing it doesn't mean
you're doing it right.
You're just doing it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Yeah.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Just like you, if you're
walking and you're getting lumbopelvic rotation,
that's playing into your problem.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Also, if I don't have, which I don't think
I do — this is one pattern of diagnosis
with me that I think is accurate, that I don't
have much terminal hip extension, so when
I walk, I'm using my lower back to fake hip
extension.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: That's what I'm telling
you.
Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Okay.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: See, that's what I'm
saying.
You really can't do that.
I mean, there's no way you won't keep injuring
your back if you keep walking like that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
How do you re-pattern or help people to adopt
so that they can use it subconsciously, new
motor patterns or new movement patterns?
Because I've been doing this for God knows
how many decades.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, not that many.
You don't look that old.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
My new best friend.
How do you help patients to get to that point
where they've changed something as fundamental
as how they walk?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, in my mind it's
twofold.
In one, we know it takes a while.
Just like if you're learning a sport or you're
learning to do anything, it takes time and
it takes attention and it takes specificity.
One is, just like we're talking about with
you, what are the most important kinds of
exercises?
What are the issues that are an impediment
to doing it the way you should do it?
What are specific exercises that can help
you and minimize those?
Then, what's really important is showing you
in your everyday activities what you should
do.
For example, if you already know that your
hip flexors, you're calling it the iliacus,
is problematic then even when you're sitting,
making sure you're not pulling with your hip
flexors to stay forward when you're sitting.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm probably doing that
right now.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I know.
I've been watching you.
It's how you even roll over or get out of
bed.
We go through every one of these things teaching
you in your everyday activities so that it
does become automatic, but it obviously takes
participation on the patient's or the subject's
part as well to learn it.
Then, it's going to take time.
I think it's important for people to realize
they can't just do 10 repetitions or three
sets of an exercise and then they're going
to move differently.
I think that's been part of what's been picked
up in my book is that you have to bring people
along, show them how to do that, and that
exercise won't change the way you move.
You have to change the way you move, and that
can improve how muscles function.
Tim Ferriss: You mentioned the psoas.
I'd actually like to come back to the psoas.
In my particular case, because I have been
an aggressive athlete, or was for several
decades and accrued an impressive number of
fractures and surgeries and so on, I get manual
—
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Oh, really?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah.
So I get manual therapy once a week, some
type of soft tissue treatment.
And what I found for me personally is it seems
like psoas major and so on, when someone does
a manual release, for whatever reason, when
they get sort of inside that pelvis a bit
more to what I've been told is the iliac,
is that's when I feel the most symptomatic
relief for my back.
But the psoas seems to hold some importance.
I don't know if you could speak to that, but
in terms of the role of psoas overactivity
as it relates to back pain, is that something
that you still feel is something people pay
too little attention to?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Oh, yeah.
I mean, I don't think it's always the cause,
but it can certainly be an exacerbator, because
the psoas attaches to the lumbar vertebrae,
and it also attaches to the intervertebral
disc.
So it's a muscle that's constantly pulling
on your back and pulling it in sort of a translation
motion.
Iliac is attached to your pelvis, so it is
not directly acting on the vertebrae the same
way the psoas is.
So in fact, people that truly have a herniated
disc and they're in that acute phase, I try
to have them do nothing with their iliopsoas.
If they want to lift their leg up, use your
hand to lift your leg up to put your shoes
on or to cross your legs or get into the car
or something if you're sitting down already,
so you minimize that use.
And just like we were talking about in quadruped,
if you are in quadruped and you want to rock
back, you will probably use the psoas to do
it.
And that's why I suggested to you to push
with your hands so you go back and you don't
use that muscle.
Well, these are small samples of what I'm
talking about as far as identifying what are
the factors that are contributing and how
do you change that in your everyday activities.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
What would be some other repeating culprits
that you see?
Let's just say someone has the symptom of
low back pain.
You take them through an assessment or identify
that they have an overactive psoas.
What might be some other low-hanging fruit
with respect to helping them to identify common
patterns or positions that contribute to that
overactivity?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, in some ways I
would be looking more specifically at which
particular movements do it and then try to
identify.
For example, it would be hard for me to believe
this, but if your hip flexors — and it makes
a difference.
The tensor fascia latae is a hip flexor, but
it has a rotational component that's much
stronger than the psoas does.
The psoas has more anterior pull.
The tensor fascia latae is going to pull more
on the pelvis.
And I will tell you that in my judgment, and
I don't think I'm way off on this, at least
70 percent of the people with back pain, it's
because their hip's not moving optimally.
And you said it yourself: "My hip is not moving
and then it bothers my back."
Well, that's exactly what goes on.
And it doesn't take some big structural fault
to have that, just a difference in the passive
tension.
So usually with younger people, if I'm going
to generalize about back pain, it's related
to their spine flexing.
Because when you're younger, you're more flexible.
And I think the other thing that's tied to
that, while we're talking about the hip, is
they're identifying more and more that hips,
what they call femoroacetabular impingement,
hips aren't flexing as much.
There's structural changes going on.
So if your hip only flexes 90 degrees, then
you want to bend over, you're going to do
it much more in your back because your hip's
not doing it.
So I want to know all the things that relate
to flexion.
In the older person, then it's more related
to extension, just like the stenosis thing.
Stenosis is, that's when you really can't
extend.
That's why you see old people walking bent
over, why they need a walker when they're
bending over.
And then the element of rotation.
And because it's not just, is it one iliopsoas
that's problematic, or both of them, one tensor
that's pulling more strongly than the other
— and that's the passive tension, not just
the active tension.
And that's what you have to know.
Tim Ferriss: Now, you were asking about my
breathing and the deep breath.
When I met with Eric, and I could be totally
screwing up this terminology, so you may need
to rein me in, but had me take off my shirt.
And I think it was, I had a very low, it might
be high, but infrasternal angle.
So I have a bit of a depression in the chest.
I have a very minimal ability to expand my
rib cage.
I'm a belly breather.
And I've had a number of people note that
it's likely when I breathe, I kind of rotate
my entire rib cage backwards, which also causes
that excessive —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: [inaudible].
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
That excessive hinging at the lumbar.
What do you do with somebody who's got this
type of predicament or pattern?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, usually, as I
was saying before, if your rib cage doesn't
expand, then it's often because your abdominals
are too taut.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And so one of the ways
is to elongate them, so arms up over your
head and take in a deep breath, and just trying
to increase the — I mean, you probably know
that with breathing you've got two modes of
movement.
One they call pump handle and the other is
bucket handle.
Tim Ferriss: I'd love for you to elaborate
on that.
Yeah.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Okay.
Well, pump handle means the front of your
chest, your sternum, is going up like a pump,
and bucket handle is like the sides expand.
And so with arms up overhead, you want to
really think about now lifting your chest
as well as pushing your rib cage out.
Tim Ferriss: Laterally, you mean?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
Laterally, like it's all going up.
And then — yep, yep.
Can you do that?
Can you take —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's sad.
Yeah, I don't have much.
It doesn't do much.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, I know, but that
—
Tim Ferriss: As it stands right now, yeah.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: That's what you need
to do.
And then here's the other thing that if you
stand with your back against the wall, and
then you try to do a side bend, but, but,
but, you want to make sure the side bend you're
moving through, that the axis of rotation's
through your chest, not in your lumbar spine.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Yeah, that'll be —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Because that would make
—
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it'd make my symptoms worse.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And you want to be sure,
Tim, that you don't just pull yourself over.
You want to try to fall like you've got a
heavy elbow.
In other words, don't contract the muscles
on the same side, but try to get these to
elongate, so like a falling over —
Tim Ferriss: Right, on the opposite side.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: — more passive elongation
rather than an active contraction.
Now, you're not going to go real far initially,
unless you've got a really heavy elbow.
Tim Ferriss: So the axis of rotation should
be —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Through the middle of
your chest.
Tim Ferriss: — or the fulcrum should be
the middle of the chest.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, right.
I always like to say, I don't care how far
you go, I care how you get there.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, okay.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Don't push it for big
range, and just make sure you're not moving
your lumbar spine and that you're doing your
thoracic spine.
Tim Ferriss: And are you breathing in those
positions or is the stretching your intercostals?
Or what is the objective of the side bend?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: The objective is to
elongate those abdominals that are not letting
you —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I see.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And the other thing
is just even when you were doing this — well,
you don't have any symptoms at all when you're
sitting there right now?
Tim Ferriss: I have a little tightness in
my low back.
I'm sitting in a chair with lumbar support.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Why do you do that when
you have too much lumbar curve anyway?
Tim Ferriss: Well, because I've noticed that
for whatever reason, symptomatically, I get
relief with a small amount of lumbar support
—
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: With a small amount,
okay.
Yeah, because you're —
Tim Ferriss: — because a flat back chair,
and I end up kind of falling forward and flattening
my back, it ends up hurting me much more later.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, because you're
getting a translation motion.
But okay, what if you put your arms up over
your head and take a deep breath?
Does that decrease your symptoms at all?
Tim Ferriss: I would say doesn't noticeably
— I don't have any severe symptoms right
this instant.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: No, but it doesn't,
okay.
Tim Ferriss: It doesn't worsen it, for sure.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: But it doesn't make
it any better either.
Tim Ferriss: It might lessen it slightly.
The degree of pain right now I would say is
pretty low, so it's hard for me to monitor.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: That's good and again,
if you look at it from the standpoint, the
more you move someplace else besides your
back, the better off you're going to be.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, definitely.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I mean, so that's part
of the whole strategy is make sure, because
usually the problem is that motion that's
problematic is occurring during all of your
activities.
The body follows the rules of physics.
It takes the path of least resistance.
So if it's easy to move there, it keeps moving
there, and that's what you're trying to change
to make it easier to move at other places
where you should be moving more.
Tim Ferriss: This seems to me to be very,
very, very important.
Would you mind just saying that again, just
reiterating that the body follows the path
of least resistance, so if you have a worn
groove and it's leading to pathology, you
need to sort of grease a different groove?
Could you just speak to that?
Because it strikes me —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: You're doing a beautiful
job yourself.
I don't think you need me.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I'm great at pontificating.
I just need to change my movements.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Okay, Father Superior.
Tim Ferriss: No, I talk a good game.
I just have to fix my movement patterns and
my breathing.
But I like how you phrase it.
I mean, the body is going to take the path
of least resistance.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm going to follow these
exercises.
I'll experiment with the elongation.
I wanted to add one more data point, which
is if I do, for instance, Pilates classes
with someone who's very technical, if I'm
in that flexed position, which tends to be
more comfortable for my back, if I'm experiencing
a lot of symptoms —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Tell me, are you supine?
Tim Ferriss: I am supine.
Yes.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Okay.
You're supine.
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And then what are you
going to do?
Tim Ferriss: Basically what I'm trying to
sort out for myself is if the overly contracted
abdominal resting state can contribute to
the symptoms I'm experiencing, what I have
also experienced is if I do a workout that
seems to be focused or is focused on a lot
of core musculature and pelvis work and so
on, that my low back doesn't bother me for
a few hours after that workout.
And I don't know how to interpret that.
Maybe these things are not at odds.
Maybe they can both be true for different
reasons.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, I mean, it depends
on what your workout is.
But what would be bad in the long run is if
you're doing a lot of holding your legs up
and moving those around while you're supine,
because again, you're going to be using your
iliopsoas, and it's going to be pulling on
your back.
The big thing is for you to be able to contract.
I'm getting the picture from you that I didn't
have before, that here you are with an increased
lumbar curve and that your lower abdominals
aren't as taut.
And lower abdominals, I mean external obliques,
not just the ones that are lower.
And when you contract those muscles that they
tend to flatten your back and decrease your
symptoms.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Mm-hmm.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And so that would be
to me, what the advantage is when you're supine
and starting to do the exercise.
What would be not the long run good is if
you're holding your legs up and trying to
do something with your legs while you're holding
that position because you're building in too
much activity from the iliopsoas.
So if anything, in that position, I would
just have you slide your leg down and try
to keep your pelvis from tilting.
Put your hands on your — I'm sure you probably
know what ASISes are: anterior superior iliac
spine.
Tim Ferriss: I do.
On the front of the of the hip.
Yeah.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: That's what I thought.
Yep, yep.
And just make sure they don't tilt as you
slide —
Tim Ferriss: For people who are wondering,
could you just describe what that is since
—
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: It's a little bony prominence
on the front of your pelvis, and some of your
major hip flexors attach there.
But it's also an indication of what your pelvis
is doing as far as tilting forward or tilting
backward.
And in your case, what you want to do is not
have it tilt forward.
So the importance of that exercise would be
that you can move your legs without your pelvis
tilting anteriorly.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: But I wouldn't put a
big load on them.
I would only have them slide down like you're
sliding your heel along the supporting surface.
Get it all the way down on one leg with no
tilt.
See if you can do the same thing with the
other.
If you have difficulty, from what we've talked
about before, if you take them out in abduction,
you should be able to get them down easier
because your tensor is going to be pulling
on your pelvis as well.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
So for people listening, if I'm interpreting
this correctly, if your legs are separated,
so your legs end up more in a snow angel type
of position as opposed to directly in front
of your hips.
Now is that predominantly a diagnostic or
is it also a training move, that sliding heel?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: All of the above.
Tim Ferriss: All the above.
Okay.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I mean, that's the nice
thing about going through an exam in which
you're looking for this path of least resistance,
the motion that is occurring too readily because
it'll occur too readily with all of the activities.
It goes back to what we were saying before.
Then you try to make sure that you're either
not getting that motion or you're moving where
you should be moving.
Yeah, so when you're taking people through
the exam, and I think this is what's so valuable,
is you're also showing them how to be in charge
of their symptoms because nothing is more
scary than "Here comes the pain, what did
I do?
How did I do it?
How do I get out of it?"
And if you're showing people, if you go this
way, it hurts, if you do it this other way,
it doesn't hurt, and then — and that's helps
also with people following the program that's
recommended because their symptoms are — they're
in charge of them, and they know what to do
to decrease them.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, this personal experience
has been incredibly frustrating, kind of horrifying,
because it's the first time in my life — if
you tear a labrum in your shoulder or you
break an arm or break a collarbone, it's oftentimes
reasonably straightforward, or it seems that
way.
Whereas, with this lower back pain, I would
feel better for three days, and then I would
wake up and I would just be in incredible,
like eight out of 10, nine out of 10 pain.
And I could not identify what the cause was.
And there've been times when my QL and my
external obliques and so on are so locked
up in the paraspinals that I can stand for
a few minutes and I have to sit down, find
something soft.
And that's not the case right now.
But the recurrence of symptoms has been so
unpredictable on some level that it's — and
a friend of mine who's in the medical profession
said, "Oh, how long have you had that?"
And I said, "Nine months."
And she said, "Well, you technically qualify
for someone with chronic pain."
And I was like, "Oh, my God, is this the new
normal?
This cannot be the new normal."
Which is why I appreciate you taking so much
time speaking about this.
When someone comes in and they have not identified
anything, they come to you for help or someone
who's trained in your system, what does the
exam look like?
What does the session look like?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, first, it's looking
at what they look like.
I mean, for me, just like if I saw you standing,
I would know a whole lot more than just looking
at you sitting because all of these things
that we've talked about indirectly, I would
see immediately.
So one is just looking at alignment.
And believe me, that's a roadmap to a whole
lot of things.
And I think it's also worth noting that it's
why people stand the way they stand is to
minimize energy expenditure.
So you can see what the passive tensions are,
which are reflective of how hypertrophied
the muscle is.
And then it's simple motions, Tim.
Have people forward bend.
Does their back flex too much?
Does it not reverse its curve with you?
And how much do their hips flex?
And typically, in men, there's more of a problem
of excessive lumbar flexion than there are
in women just because the center of gravity
is higher, the hips are stiffer, et cetera.
So how do they forward bend?
How do they rotate?
Because many people will twist rather than
really be able to rotate.
And then side bending.
Does it hurt?
Where do I see motion?
Tim Ferriss: By twist, you mean their pelvis
follows them instead of that sort of —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: No.
Tim Ferriss: No?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: See, that's the other
thing that's interesting is because I'm sure
with you, people have looked at what your
range of motion is in your hips.
But when you're standing, you don't have that
same range of motion.
Your pelvis won't rotate on your femurs the
same amount.
So one, does your hips not move and therefore
you have to move in your back —
Tim Ferriss: The back.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: — because your pelvis
isn't rotating?
Or is it asymmetrical?
And then the other thing is that actually,
ironically, if your abdominals are really
good, instead of sort of rotating off more
of an axis, though it's not perfect, your
trunk shifts over because if your trunk shifts
over in a twisting motion, it's because your
abdominals won't elongate easily.
Tim Ferriss: Fascinating.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: So we're looking for
— and then which one of these motions causes
symptoms?
When I see that it's bad, I will correct it.
For example, if you had pain side-bending,
then I'd put my hand above your iliac crest,
have you side-bend again.
And if I've blocked it and you don't have
pain, then I know that that motion occurring
there is causing your pain.
If when you —
Tim Ferriss: The movement of the pelvis —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: The movement of the
back —
Tim Ferriss: — or the iliac crest.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And the same thing,
if you bend over and there's no pain, but
you come back up and you lead with your back
rather than your hips, then that causes pain.
Then I know again, that extending is causing
your symptoms.
And then if your symptoms, as you've reported,
get better when you bend over, again, I know
that extension's causing your symptoms.
And then I go through little tests in supine
to see the length of the hip flexor muscles.
I look to see what your symptoms are in supine.
If you have symptoms, just like you sort of
suggested, if we flex your hips and knees,
you ought be more comfortable than when they're
down straight.
If I abduct your hips, I know what's causing
it that way.
Do you see what I mean?
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: So then I will passively
move your hips to see what the range is, make
sure it's passive.
Then I'll have you do it actively to see if
that elicits symptoms, show you how to change
it.
I'm going through an exam looking for that
movement that shows up consistently.
If I stop it or improve it, symptoms go down.
So we do in the supine, side-lying, prone,
quadruped, sitting, watch people walk, everything
that gives them pain.
They get in and out of their car, how to roll,
how to go up and down stairs.
Whatever activities would give them pain,
I'll go through them with them.
Tim Ferriss: And is the assessment largely
the same for athletes versus non-athletes?
It's pretty much —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: That's a really interesting
point because in some ways people have a hard
time because I'm looking for little baby things.
Ironically, there's really good research that's
been done by Linda Van Dillen, and these movements
that cause the symptoms occur very early and
they're only a few degrees.
And so sometimes with athletes I've had the
issue that, well, these are just baby things
and they don't really matter.
But they do matter.
You've got to stop that, and then you can
build on bigger ways.
There's a therapist by the name of Robbie
Ohashi who's put these into — it's like
a movement spectrum.
It's not the exact words.
I'm blanking on it right now.
Where you do isolated exercises, combined
exercises, and then more putting them together
for your sport, whether it's tennis or whatever.
And he's seen a lot of athletes.
And that's the whole idea is that you get
somebody to correct the little bitty movements,
and then you build on the more complicated,
the more demanding movements.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Do you have an opinion of, I've
not experienced this personally, but something
called DNS?
I think it's dynamic neuromuscular —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Neuromuscular Stabilization.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
And it seems like they build based on some
sort of motor skill development chronology
from childhood.
So you'd start with supine or prone, and then
move to crawling or something like that, quadruped,
and then kneeling and so on.
Do you have any perspective on this or could
you —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, to be perfectly
honest, I think you're already grown.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, got it.
Yep.
Certainly, if my shiny pate is any indication,
then yes.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Looking at your well-shaved
head, I'm always reminded of what my father
used to say who was also bald from an early
age.
And he would always say "Grass can't grow
on a busy street."
Tim Ferriss: That's hilarious.
Definitely going to use that.
Yeah, I know.
Yes.
No, grass cannot grow on a busy street.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I don't think you need
to stage it like that.
That's why I go through the whole exam and
look at the finished product that needs some
fine-tuning, the thing we talked about in
the beginning, and that movement-causing pathology
and the fact that it's really your everyday
activities that cause it in the first place.
And so that's why you've got to change the
way you're doing basic things.
Do you know what I mean?
I do.
And look at that because that's what caused
the problem.
That's what you need to change.
Tim Ferriss: What is, I believe you call it
collapso-smasho.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Where did you get — I
didn't put that down.
Well, there are two forms here.
It relates to this fact that what we talked
about already, that the abdominals can get
— well, that the spine suffers from compression
type things.
And in the older individual without muscles,
it's collapso-smasho.
In younger individuals like yourself or others
who have done a whole lot of abdominal exercises,
I call it squeezo-smasho because the passive
tension from those muscles is adding to the
compression.
And the older people are people who are hypermobile,
and it's kind of collapsing down without enough
support.
So it's not good if you don't have enough
muscle, and it's not good if you have too
much muscle.
It's what's in between that's most important.
Tim Ferriss: So how do you find the Goldilocks
amount of —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: No pain and they look
great.
Tim Ferriss: Keep fine-tuning.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And the other thing
is obviously we aren't all built the same.
I think that's one of the other important
things is looking for structural variations
and building that into the assessment.
That's the part that's tricky.
People don't always pick the right parents,
and when they find out, it's too late to go
back.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
So let's talk about perhaps other common pathological
patterns.
I've read that you've said, or written perhaps,
that most people wear their shoulders too
low.
Could you speak to that and perhaps also mention
what corrective measures can be taken?
What does it mean for people to wear their
shoulders too low?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, it means that
they should sit up at an angle that is about
six degrees or so higher.
And often you see when — you don't look
so bad, but when people have done a lot of
weight training, that's one end of this game,
you'll see that their shoulders look really
dropped.
They look lower.
So at the end of their shoulder —
Tim Ferriss: They look like they're sloped
downward.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
If you know there's the cervical vertebrae
between C6 and C7, you should have — that's
about the level where your shoulders should
be.
And so if that's way down, you can look at
your clavicle and you see that there's not
this six degree angle, but your shoulder is
lower than your —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I see.
So the clavicle should, from inside to outside,
have roughly a six-degree upward angle.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Should have a little
tilt to it, upward angle.
Right.
So it could be too low.
And then the other way I like to talk about
it is just the weight of the world, the husband,
the children, the bra straps, all of that
pulling down and women's shoulder girdles
aren't as stiff.
And what's important about this is it's not
only a factor of what it does to your shoulders,
it also does a number on your neck because
the muscles that help to hold your shoulder
blades up attach to your cervical vertebrae.
And the really big important thing on trying
to address that is using, I think the muscle
that's named the serratus anterior.
The serratus anterior attaches to your ribcage
and it can act like a sling, so it attaches
to your rib cage and to your shoulder blades.
So it's like a sling that can help to hold
your shoulder blades up and take some of that
load off of your cervical spine as well as
put your shoulders in the right position.
And having your shoulders sitting at the right
position is important for the glenohumeral
joint for all of the shoulder joint motions
to work without subjecting them to too much
injury.
Tim Ferriss: It seems like perhaps in weight
training, I don't know if this contributes
to the sloped shoulders and maybe the flat
or downward angle of the clavicle, but the
advice to depress and retract your shoulders
is common for any number of exercises.
And I recall meeting with Eric and what he
has a lot of his athletes do, and this is
very individual dependent, so I'm not making
a blanket recommendation, and I'm not speaking
for Eric, but for instance, as he has someone
maybe retract on some type of standing, pulling
motion with say, some type of cable machine,
he'll have them reach forward with the opposing
side.
And it seems to me that there's less of that
fixed, depressed and retracted position in
a lot of what he recommends.
Is working on the serratus anterior, doing
exercises for the serratus anterior, enough
to correct that downward sloped angle in people
who have that as a current state of affairs?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Number one is also you
have to be sure when people have worked out,
now it depends upon, again, what their workout
routine is.
If they're somebody that hangs and does chin-ups,
one of the things can be the latissimus dorsi,
is this big muscle, and people do lap cool
downs, et cetera, or they do climbing things
or hanging things, and that muscle will pull
your shoulders down.
So you've got to make sure that that muscle
hasn't got too short and that you can get
your arms up over your head in the first place.
Number two is what you really want to do is
use the upper trapezius and the exercises
where you're down here is using the rhomboids
and the middle trapezius, and those don't
—
Tim Ferriss: And just for people who are listening,
this is like a rowing motion, is that what
—
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, anything where
your arms are below your shoulders or at the
level of your shoulders, you're using muscles,
they pull your shoulder blades together, but
particularly the rhomboids downwardly rotate.
So it's going to make it more difficult to
get your scapula to upwardly rotate and to
get the upper trapezius to work.
So one of the things that is probably more
effective is actually I like to start people
off, and I think that's the other thing that
when I look at what recommendations there
are on the internet, they never show people
where to start.
It's like, do this exercise.
Well, not everybody's ready to do that exercise.
They've got to get ready to do it the way
that's recommended.
But if you can face the wall and slide your
arms up the wall, and then once your arms
get to shoulder height, particularly when
they're lower, then you shrug a little bit
to get them up and then you try to lift them
off while holding your shoulders up.
Tim Ferriss: How far are you standing from
the wall?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Right up there facing.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, got it.
Okay, got it.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Right up there facing,
your elbows are flexed.
You're sliding the little finger side of your
hands up there to get it.
And then if you just let your shoulders drop,
you've gained nothing.
But you've got to also hold them up as you
lower your arms, you see.
Tim Ferriss: Keeping your shoulders up as
you do this exercise.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Keep them up, get them
up to where they should be worn, not closer
to your ears than your iliac crest.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
So you're looking to keep the shoulders in
the position where the clavicle is angling
up slightly.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Where you want to wear
them.
Yeah.
And the other thing is it just makes such
common sense.
You can't spend the rest of the day have them
hanging down either.
So you should have a chair that has armrests
on it so that they're up when you're got your
armrests up.
If you have to stand a lot, you can put them
on your hips.
If one shoulder in particular is problematic,
you can support it with the other hand.
So again, exercises will mean nothing if you
don't follow through.
If you're doing even 20 minutes of exercise,
but you're spending 12 hours with your shoulders
hanging down, it isn't not going to work.
Tim Ferriss: What is your position on, and
I know there are many different types, but
stretching?
This can be a controversial, sometimes polarizing
topic, but could you elaborate on how various
forms of stretching should or shouldn't be
used in healthy and rehabilitating populations?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, number one is
really understanding what you're meaning by
stretching.
I've talked about this as we've gone on through
this, but I keep using the term stiffness
because I feel like I was misled during my
early days as a physical therapist when I
didn't use my own sense of looking carefully
because we were told that certain movements
occurred because a muscle was too short and
it needed to be stretched.
I'll give you an example.
Well, the example we talked about already,
if you're on your back and you slide your
legs down and your pelvis tilts forward, your
hip flexors are too short.
Well, actually what it is is the struggle
between the tension from your abdominals and
the tension from your hip flexors.
So stretching your hip flexors is not going
to fix the lack of tension in your abdominals.
And so what I find is that most often there
aren't muscles that are short, there's a relative
stiffness problem.
So improving the stiffness of your abdominals
will elongate your hip flexors.
Do you see what I mean?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
It's a relationship, not just an isolated
muscle that you need to stretch.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Right.
And that it isn't the length of the hip flexors
that's the problem.
It's the passive tension from those muscles.
Because when you're sliding your leg down,
that muscle isn't that active anyway.
And if it's related to the length of the muscle,
it shouldn't occur until you get to the end
of that muscle length, and that's not when
the tilting occurs.
So there's all these things that just don't
make sense.
So what I found through these numerous years
of experience I've had is that there's many
more problems with relative stiffness than
there is with muscles really being short.
Now, if it's really short, then you also need
to find out what's making it short, because
it doesn't just like, oh, I think I'll go
short today.
It's a matter of what is your activity?
For example, when I'm teaching courses, I
have a great picture of a young man who has
really short, he has big curve, like you're
talking about, an increased lumbar curve.
Clearly his hip flexors are short, and he's
a cyclist.
Well, you usually don't see that kind of alignment
in a cyclist.
You usually see a flatter back.
But if I didn't let him use toe clips, he
couldn't move the pedals around.
So he moved the pedals by flexing rather than
pushing.
So that's why his hip flexors were short.
So it wouldn't matter how much you stretched
them, if every time he went out to ride the
bicycle, he's using his hip flexors all over
again in a shortened position.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
So he's basically in that rear half of the
rotation of the pedal, he's pulling with his
hip flexors.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Right.
Instead of more pushing than just the lifting.
So what is it that people are doing that's
causing that muscle to get short?
Other examples, and again, I find it so interesting
about what intensive weight training is doing,
because if you're lifting, I've actually examined
young women who are lifting twice their body
weight.
Well, how many muscles do you use if you're
lifting twice your body weight in a deadlift?
Every little muscle you've got in your body.
Well, what happens is you end up training
all of those muscles to come on, and they
don't just go off, so they walk stiff-legged
because there's too much activation of these
muscles.
And so they can't stand and have muscles relaxed
because everything comes on.
It doesn't say, "I'll only come on when I'm
weight training."
You've trained them to come on, and now you've
got much more output for a given muscle than
you would otherwise.
So it's too much.
So you've got to learn also how to not activate
them as much as you're learning how to activate.
I'm not against any of this, it's just that
you need to know what all the additional factors
are that take place with this training.
So it's a long answer to the question about
stretching, but my big point is you've got
to figure out what's making it short, that
if you need constant stretching, you've got
a problem with what's making it short that
has to be addressed.
Tim Ferriss: So I've been advised, and it
seems to help a bit, but to do a fair amount
of say, hip bridging or glute activation alternated
with say, hip flexor stretches.
And if I have, in addition to that, the stiffness
in the abdominal muscles contributing to this
lower back presentation, these symptoms I'm
experiencing, could you just remind me of
how I would then work on that abdominal stiffness?
I could do the overhead breathing and the
side bends.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, that's for that
stiffness.
But again, what you're telling me, and again,
I haven't seen you standing, but —
Tim Ferriss: I could stand.
We're also on video.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: Would you like me to stand?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, please, please.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
And I can tilt the camera as needed.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Okay.
Pull up your shirt so I can see.
Tim Ferriss: There we go.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Now turn sideways for
me.
Oh, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: No, no, no.
I mean, I don't know what you're talking about,
your tummy sticking out.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, well, yeah.
I mean, if I want to look in a second trimester,
I can do this.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Which one's the real
you?
Tim Ferriss: This is probably the real me.
This is the real me.
This is how I would stand if I were standing
at an event, I would probably try to tuck
my hips a bit to take the pressure off my
back.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: But you see, you don't
have an increased lumbar curve.
You've got an increased thoracic curve.
In other words —
Tim Ferriss: Like the kyphosis on the back,
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
And part of that kyphosis, yeah, right up
there.
And part of that kyphosis comes from your
rectus abdominus pulling down on your thoracic
spine.
Tim Ferriss: Interesting.
Right here.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
And see, when you lean back like that then,
well, I'm telling you though, the rectus and
the other abdominals become your anti-gravity
muscles.
So they're constantly being used.
Tim Ferriss: Meaning I lean back and then
these are pulling me forward.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, you lean back
to get away from those, but the rectus needs
to be a little bit longer.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
This needs to be longer.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: To decrease, and the
best way for you to do that is to do the quadruped
thing and then let your thoracic spine go
down.
Tim Ferriss: Now, so that would be almost
like the cow?
No, no, the cat.
The cat cow, I guess.
As I'm on my hands and knees —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: All you need to do is
think about letting your chest go towards
the floor and you feel the load on your shoulder
blades.
Okay.
Now let me watch you just easily, like you're
going to contract your tummy to pull it in.
Yeah.
You see you do sway back.
Okay, stop.
You did lean back.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, if I'm going to —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Don't, that's it.
That's better.
Now, do you have any symptoms like that at
all?
Tim Ferriss: No.
There's a little bit of tightness here, but
it actually, it doesn't bother me right now.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, okay.
Yeah.
And it looks like your hips are fairly straight.
So go ahead and turn, put your back to me
so I can just, put your back to me for a minute
and put your hands on your iliac crest.
Now, with your hands like that, it looks like
they don't look so bad to me.
Let's do what we talked about before, put
your feet apart and let's just see what happens.
Does that, if that changes your symptoms at
all?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it seems to.
Wearing very slippery shoes.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Is it better?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's better.
I would stand, this would help if I was say,
recording a podcast.
What would help even more is if I put my one
leg up on something, if I stepped on something,
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Does it matter which
leg?
Tim Ferriss: Right leg, because where I feel
most of the pain is localized around this
bony process here.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Right, right.
Yeah.
So that is going to be the tensor on that
side.
Now let me do one more thing.
Just bend over and come back up.
Tim Ferriss: From the side like this?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Wow.
Yeah.
Now you need to work a bit on how you come
back up from forward bending.
And don't worry about going over that far.
You need to come up with your hips and less
back.
As you finish off your back, you sway back
and do too much back extension.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, when I get to the top, you're
saying?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
Yeah, about the last 30, 40 percent.
Tim Ferriss: So hinge more at the hip?
Is that what you mean?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, just think about
going over and coming back up by making your
hips extend.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Hold it there.
Now hips, just come back up with hips, hips,
hips, hips, hips.
Yeah, that was better.
Tim Ferriss: Better like that.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
And try not to let your back sway back.
You use the momentum of your upper back coming
back to finish up.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
I get a little —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And then you get a little
extension and that's not good.
Tim Ferriss: Overextension.
Yeah.
Right.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Right, right.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Anything else that I can — yeah,
I mean I can do more.
Certainly.
This is helpful.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And I think if you can
easily practice, you've got those, the lower
abdominals or the external obliques, they're
the ones that tilt your pelvis.
And if you just easily practice tightening
those, but don't work hard at it so that you
sway back.
Tim Ferriss: So this is the external obliques.
And then what was the other musculature you
mentioned?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I'm saying don't sway
back.
Just easily try to tighten them so you get
a little bit of a pelvic.
Yeah, plenty.
Now are you good that way?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm good.
I'm good.
And this would be in a standing position when
I would have just a little bit of tension
in the external waist.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: If you do that as much
as you can because you see, it eliminates
your symptoms, that's all you need to do.
And then work on that little increased thoracic
kyphosis.
Tim Ferriss: Or I guess reducing this kyphosis
by lengthening —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: If you decrease that,
then you won't sway back so much.
Tim Ferriss: I got it.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And if your rectus abdominis
elongates better, you won't have that tendency
for a thoracic kyphosis.
Tim Ferriss: And to extend then elongate the
rectus abdominis, for people listening this
is the six packs, this stuff running down
the front of the abdominal area.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I’m having a hard
time hearing you, Tim.
Tim Ferriss: Sorry.
Yeah, that’s right.
I forgot about the microphone over here.
That to elongate the rectus abdominis, I could
get in that quadruped position and basically
drop my chest to the floor as I'm pushing
my hips backwards if I'm here.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Just in that position,
just let it go down.
Yeah.
It's amazing how much you can improve your
alignment and it looks like you could change
pretty readily.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, great.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And the big thing, so
we started off because you were doing the
bridging exercise.
I wouldn't be tempted to do that.
One, you'll do a much better loading of your
gluteal muscles by that bending over and coming
back up with your hip extensors.
And if you tighten it there, there's also
a tendency for the glutes to actually posteriorly
tilt the pelvis, but the spine doesn't go
along for the ride.
Tim Ferriss: Could you say more about that,
please?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, it's like this
is one of my guilt trips because many years
ago I was working to get the point across.
I'll tell you my little story.
Tim Ferriss: Yes, please.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I was working with this
older woman, I thought old was my age now.
And so she did have spinal stenosis and I
was working on sit to stand, so she didn't
have any symptoms.
And I had her try to tighten her abdominals
and she was doing pretty good.
And then I said, "Okay, now let's tighten
your gluteal muscles as you get up."
Well, she did that and she got pain shooting
down her legs.
And the reason being that your gluteal muscles,
as you know, attach to the pelvis, so they
posteriorly tilt the pelvis, but if the spine
doesn't want to go along for the ride, it
stays there and you get a translation motion
between where pelvis is moving and the vertebrae
are not moving.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
The gluteal muscles are basically pulling
the pelvis out from under the spine in a sense.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Exactly.
Exactly.
Not a good idea.
Tim Ferriss: Not a good idea.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Now, if your spine moves
easily, then that's all right.
And you can get the same effect if you would
put your hand where your spine is and tighten
your glutes, you'll see your spine doesn't
move.
Do you see what I mean?
If it wants to go along for the ride, it'll
go along for the ride.
But the problem is those people where it doesn't
want to go along for the ride and you're going
to be one of them.
Tim Ferriss: So in what ways do I need to
be careful then, or I guess —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I just don't think that's
a good exercise for you.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
The bridging?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: The bridging.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I feel, especially if I do bridging single-leg,
but even double-legged, I remember it's been
recommended to me by a number of PTs and I've
told them, I'm like, "Guys, this really bothers
my back."
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, yeah.
It's arching your back.
It's not a good plan.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Okay.
I'll skip those.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I would skip those.
When do you have time to do all this?
Tim Ferriss: I don't.
I don't.
That's honestly, Shirley, been one of the
compounding factors that has been so frustrating.
It's not only am I getting very often, entirely
different diagnoses, but I also get 37 different
programs and there's just no way that I can
fit them in.
And many are probably conflicting also.
And I've found the movement-focused approach
to make a lot of, at least intuitive sense
to me.
If our entire conscious experience of reality
is modeled on a brain that is evolved to move
us through space, it just seems to make sense
that that is the variable to pay a lot of
attention to because it's not just a variable,
but a system of systems as you put it, much
like the immune system.
So it makes a whole lot of sense.
Now, you just mentioned older woman, but she's
now my age.
Would you mind sharing your age, but also
your own self-care, I suppose, routine?
What do you do to keep as sharp and as in
shape as you are?
I would love to know more about that.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, next month I'll
be 86 years old.
Tim Ferriss: It's incredible.
It's just amazing.
I would never have guessed in a million years.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I'm so lucky.
I'm so fortunate too, because I don't mind
saying both of my parents had dementia and
I've now exceeded their ages both in life
and in dementia.
Right now I don't know that I have any.
Tim Ferriss: I certainly can't, I would not
think you have any.
Very, very sure.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: So far, so good.
Tim Ferriss: So far, so good.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: As I told you, that
very early, number one, choosing to be a physical
therapist.
And also I was very fortunate because growing
up I refused to grow up and I played sports.
In my day, it's, when are you going to grow
up and stop all that stuff?
And that was very good.
We also didn't have air conditioning, and
we only had one car.
So instead of paying more for a bicycle than
a car, I had to ride a big old bicycle and
ride it everywhere.
And so I happily laid down enough bone and
enough muscle in my early years.
And then the physician that I encountered
who was part of the Department of Medicine
at Washington University in St. Louis, his
name was John Holloszy, he started bringing
in the lifestyle issues.
And as a physical therapist, even though I
got a PhD in neurobiology because I wanted
to solve the motor control problems of the
stroke patient, I stayed very physically active.
I started really running and doing things
when I started my PhD studies, and after encountering
this physician and learned a bit about nutrition,
breaking all the family tendencies.
So basically, and then again, learning about
musculoskeletal problems, even though I was
really interested in working with neurological
patients, people with spinal cord injury,
head injury, stroke, I had always had this
tendency to look at how people moved.
And I tried to figure out why they were moving
the way they were moving, et cetera, and got
involved with musculoskeletal patients and
they started getting better.
So I had to figure that out.
And then I applied my own ideas to myself.
In fact, I don't know how folks who you want
to get at, but there're really some funny
stories connected with that.
Tim Ferriss: Let's do it.
Oh, yeah, no, we love funny stories around
here.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, and it really
related to doing this quadruped little exercise
because, so one funny story was, I was really
poor going through getting my PhD because
I didn't have any income then and was living
off of a minimum amount of money.
And so I didn't get to buy new clothes very
often.
And I had a pair of slacks that I was wearing
for a long time, and a friend actually took
me out to play golf.
And it was an older woman at that time and
we're out playing golf.
And she says, "Shirley, you've got your pants
on backwards."
And I said, "I'm working on my PhD.
I think I ought to be able to know how to
put my pants on."
And so we started looking at the darts, and
sure enough, I had them on backwards.
Well, before my alignment was such that they
looked all right.
But now that I was doing this quadruped exercise,
they didn't look all right.
They were looking funny because I had changed
the curves in my back and my buttocks.
And so that's why she caught the idea that
I wasn't wearing my pants right.
Tim Ferriss: Which quadruped movements were
these?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: It's just the idea of
being in quadruped and just letting your back
go down and then locking back.
I tended to sit, ride the bicycle.
I was a catcher for three different softball
teams, so I was really in a posterior tilt
with a really flat back, and I had never really
gone the other way.
Tim Ferriss: And just for people who are listening,
if you don't know, just to imagine, if you
imagine the pelvis as a bowl of soup, posterior
tilt, you're kind of pouring soup out the
back of your pelvis,
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Holding it in the middle.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Yeah.
Right.
Got it.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: So your whole back goes
flat then.
Tim Ferriss: And when you're pushing your
hips back, you were facilitating more of a
natural curve in the lower back.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I was getting my hips
to bend and letting my back go down so I was
getting more of a curve, and I think also
decreasing a bit of a tendency towards the
thoracic kyphosis.
The other thing that was really interesting,
I used to bowl with a bowling ball.
And while I was in my PhD program, which took
me six years, I didn't have any money to bowl.
And so when I went and got my bowling ball
out again, I had to change the finger grips
because I had stretched my finger flexors
out.
And so the finger grips no longer fit me because
my fingers were longer.
Tim Ferriss: So could you explain that?
So your grips had been molded to fingers that
were —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, my finger flexors
because yeah, my fingers were always flexed
from everything I did.
And I never really thought about stretching
them out.
And so when you're in quadruped, you would
have stretching those around.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Okay, I see.
So for people who are listening, because we're
making movements with our hands and gestures
with the hands, instead of being the keyboard
position, we're going to make the video available
as well but some people will only hear audio.
So instead of being sort of that keyboard,
hawk talon position, when you're in quadruped,
as if you were doing a pushup but not that
pushup position, if your hands are flat on
the floor, then you're going to be stretching
those flexors.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Stretching across the
wrist and across the fingers, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, got it.
So you had to change your bowling ball.
That's wild.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah.
And then the other thing is I had always worn
my shoes off so that they were going off to
the side.
And after I did this few years of this quadruped
rocking, I didn't walk in the same way and
my shoes weren't worn off to the side from
just walking.
Tim Ferriss: Interesting.
So worn off to the side, you mean the shoes
on the inside were worn or on the —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Like the outside of
the right and the inside of the left.
So there were all these little changes that
took place just from improving my alignment
partly with that.
So to go on to answer your full question,
so what do I do these days?
Guess what?
I still do quadruped.
I don't go all the way back and sit on my
heels.
And I also want to tell you about one thing
people need to know about that exercise.
And then I do a modified, I do pushups, modified
pushups.
And then in prone, and I think that if you
could do this carefully it'd be good, is in
prone, I passively, I flex my knee so that
my leg as much as possible is falling on my
thigh.
Do you understand?
Tim Ferriss: So is this similar to what you're
describing, you're laying down on your chest
—
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, I'm laying down,
face down, bend my knee, and I try to get
my leg, just one knee, to fall back on my
thigh.
Because I don't want to hold it down at 90.
In other words, if you bend your knee, you
can go to 90 degrees.
If you go more than 90 degrees, your leg is
falling on your thigh.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Right.
Your lower leg is sort of falling onto your
hamstring.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, got it.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: That's your thigh.
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And in that position,
then I lift my thigh off of the floor.
I do hip extension, but not high.
There's only 10 degrees of motion.
But it's a way to stretch, it's a way to use
your gluteal muscle.
Because if you use your hamstring, you'll
get a cramp.
You'll get a bad cramp in your hamstring.
So just a little bit of hip extension to use
my gluteal muscle.
Tim Ferriss: How many repetitions are you
doing on each side or what is —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I just do 10 repetitions
on one side and then 10 repetitions on the
other.
Tim Ferriss: And you're doing roughly 10 repetitions
of the quadruped rocking as well?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: I'm not sure if that's the right
amount.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: 15 pushups, 15 modified
pushups.
Modified is your knees are bent.
I don't go to my toes.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Okay.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And then still in the
prone position, knees flex to 90 degrees,
and then I do hip rotation in both directions,
letting my lower leg come in and then go out.
Come in and go out.
Tim Ferriss: So just if I can translate, and
please correct me if I'm getting this wrong,
but you're bending, you're laying on your
chest, one leg bent to 90 degrees and basically
windshield wiper with that lower leg on each
side.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: But I do both at the
same time.
Tim Ferriss: You do both at the same time.
I see.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: So they're not quite
— one's maybe 80, the other maybe 70.
Because it doesn't take all that long.
And then with my knees extended straight,
with my lower extremities straight, I alternate
doing hip extension, but I think about using
my gluteal muscle.
I think about activating my gluteus maximus.
And again, only about 10 degrees of hip extension.
And then in that same position I do hip abduction.
In other words, one leg out to the side 10
times.
Because you use your gluteus medias and that
better if you're working against gravity and
extension than you do when you're supine.
Supine, you tend to recruit the tensor too
much.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Got it.
And is there anything that follows that abductor?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, then I go supine,
turnover.
And I think this is really — I'm pretty
good about not having a kyphosis, but I have
to adduct.
In supine, I adduct, pull my shoulder blades
together and slide my arms up over my head
so that my arms are all the way up over my
head as much as I can.
And I'm on a hard floor.
And I'm starting with my hips and knees bent,
arms up overhead, and then slide one leg down,
slide the other leg down.
And believe me, for an older person who's
got a tendency towards collapse-o-smash-o,
really just getting yourself as stretched
out as possible is so important.
I mean, really.
Tim Ferriss: Sounds like for me with my kyphosis
that would also be important.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: And the biggest worry
is going to be with the older person, that
if you have a kyphosis, you're not going to
be able to get your arms on the floor all
the way up over your head.
And no pain.
You don't want any pain on top of your shoulder
because that's not going to be a good plan.
So they may need to have a pillow up there
when they're first starting so their arms
don't go all the way back.
Because you want to avoid any kind of pain
on top of your shoulder.
But happily, I know how to do it.
I can do it.
And then I do actively hip and knee flex.
Bring one knee towards my chest, put it down,
then the other one.
And 10 times with each leg.
And then with one foot on the floor, I do
a straight leg raise.
But I don't tighten all my leg, my thigh muscles
so that my knee is perfectly straight.
And I turn it out a little bit so that I don't
use the tensor.
I want it that if I rotate it out, you'll
use the psoas more.
And I think about tightening my abdominals.
Because I have had a significant problem,
and I don't want to put too much stress on
my lumbar spine from the iliopsoas.
I want to use it, but I want to protect my
back.
That's why I have one foot on the floor.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
That's why you're doing one leg at a time.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, yeah.
It's certainly one leg at a time.
Tim Ferriss: So could you just reiterate why,
so given the past lumbar issue, why you would
want to engage the psoas instead of the TFL
in this case?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Because I think it's
a good muscle to use.
I need to be able to flex my hip.
But the tensor, it has a real low threshold
for activation.
Interestingly enough, if you would scratch
the bottom of your foot, the first muscle
would go off, will be your tensor fasciae
latae.
Tim Ferriss: No kidding.
Wild.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: In fact, I think it's
so interesting because I've tried to contact
the World Health Organization because all
over the world, the tensor is run amok, but
they don't want to listen to me.
Tim Ferriss: They're not returning the calls?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: No, I know.
And it is this little bitty wimpy muscle and
you say how can it cause so much trouble?
But it sure does.
It plays a role in what happens to the knee.
It plays a role in what happens to the back
and the hip.
It's an evil thing.
Anyway.
But an interesting thing, one of my colleagues
was doing a study and we actually had a student
that did not have a tensor fasciae latae.
Tim Ferriss: No kidding.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, we didn't throw
her out of school or anything.
But anyway, I couldn't wait to do all the
tests that we do to look for the length of
the tensor.
And she was a fair athlete, so it wasn't like
it had been sitting not doing anything if
it was there.
And I did all the tests and they were negative,
which was kind of supportive to me that indeed
the tensor does do things that aren't so kind
to the rest of the body.
So anyway, all that to say that's why when
I do the straight leg raise, I try to laterally
rotate my hip, because I'd rather use the
psoas than I would.
And it's not causing any problems.
Clearly if I thought I was injuring myself,
I would not do that.
And then I do one other thing.
With one leg straight and the other foot on
the floor so that my knee is bent, my foot's
on the floor, I let my leg go out to the side.
And that's my way of trying to work on controlling
rotation with the trunk.
My leg goes out to the side, it wants to rotate
your pelvis, but contracting your abdominals
prevents that rotation.
So that's another way I'm trying to work my
abdominals.
And then I stand up.
I'm so proud of myself because I can get up
from the floor without any difficulty, and
many people at my age or many years younger
than that can't do that.
And put my back to the wall and then do what
I was telling you to do, arms up overhead
and do the little side bend thing.
Tim Ferriss: And you do this every day?
Or how many —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I do.
And I walk three to four miles a day.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Sometimes ride a stationary
bike.
Tim Ferriss: Well, these are things I'm paying
more and more attention to.
I'm so impressed.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: But let me tell you
one thing now, Tim, that the quadruped, as
much as I love it and I think it's important,
whether you have a shoulder problem, a cervical
problem, et cetera, is that one of the things
that's a problem though is, and it can be
for several reasons, but again, the tensor
is one of them.
If you rock back and your hip medially rotates,
in other words I've found this in some patients
that as you rock back, your hips should just
flex.
But if you are monitoring the femur, you can
sometimes see that it medially rotates.
That is really bad.
And the reason why it's really bad is because
it's rotating in your knee joint too.
And that's a good way to set yourself up for
an ACL tear, anterior cruciate ligament.
And I think people should be monitoring that,
anybody that's doing that.
One of the things that helps is if you slightly
laterally rotate your hips.
Many people, particularly men, come with what
we call femoral retroversion.
Do you know what that is?
Tim Ferriss: I don't.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Okay.
Well, you probably have it.
Femoral retroversion — no, it's a structural
variation.
And so the femur, as you know, has a head
and neck on it.
It's angled.
Well, it's also rotated on the shaft.
And if it's in the ideal world, the average,
not the normal, the average is that that rotation
is 15 degrees.
So the head and neck of the femur are pointing
15 degrees forward.
Now, many men, it's not rotated.
So what it means is that when you're doing
your hip rotation, you go out a long ways,
but you don't go in.
Tim Ferriss: That's true for me, for sure.
My internal rotation is terrible compared
to my external rotation.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: But that's because you
came that way and it should never change.
No, I mean it.
And men need to know that.
In fact, that's a problem because if your
tensor is really developed, you could be sitting
in hip medial rotation when you shouldn't
be.
And if your glutes are really good, that'll
also immediately rotate your hip when you're
sitting.
That's a problem.
But one of the ways to, if you're trying to
do the quadruped thing, is to turn your hip
out a little bit when you're in the quadruped
position so your feet would come together
a little bit closer.
Tim Ferriss: Right, more of like a wrestling
par terre position, meaning —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I don't know.
I never wrestled.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I can pick up the slack on explaining that.
That's from —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Not with a referee,
anyway.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Anyway.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
So from the feet to the knees, it would just
be making a very, very, very slight V-shape.
It's not a V-shape, but the lines would converge,
in other words, behind you.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Your feet would be a
little bit closer together.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
You're funny.
All right, so that makes a lot of sense to
me and I'm certainly comfortable with that.
What would it mean or how would you read the
movement pattern that I have of sitting and
having my legs sort of splay open?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Really good.
Tim Ferriss: That's also something really
good that alleviates my low back symptoms.
If I'm sitting in a chair, oftentimes I'll
take my shoes off and fold them up on top
of the chair.
Restaurants hate this by the way, so I do
get chastised occasionally.
But it alleviates some of my lower back issues.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: You're getting it fore
and aft.
Because you're probably in this — this is
one of the syndromes I have of the hip, that
I've described of the hip.
Because if your tensors really develop, it's
going to be holding your femur in medial rotation
when you're standing because it's pulled taught
then.
If your gluteals are really well-developed,
when your hip's flexed to 90 degrees, they
become medial rotators too.
So they're trying to hold your hip in medial
rotation.
And you're probably getting that twist on
your back then.
Do you see what I mean?
So when you laterally rotate your hips, then
you're taking that pull off of them.
Tim Ferriss: Taking the pressure off of it,
yeah.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: You're not getting that
extra pull on your pelvis from those gluteal
muscles being pulled so taught.
And that's where you should be.
That's your normal thing because you have
femoral retroversion.
That's one of the things that's bad is because
when people go in and they're taught deadlifts
and they say make your feet point straight
ahead.
Well, many men in particular shouldn't have
their feet pointing straight ahead because
they have this femoral retroversion.
Also, when they do things that rotate, like
play golf, their feet should be turned out.
Because if they're straight ahead, they're
at the end of their medial rotation range.
Do you see what I mean?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that makes sense.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: So then it will be the
knee or the back or the hips that are going
to go.
Tim Ferriss: Makes a lot of sense, yeah.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: It's also interesting.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, super fascinating.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, it's like the
backbone is attached to the pelvic bone.
And I think to me, that's what's so valuable
about being a physical therapist or looking
at people.
Because I can't, like an orthopedic surgeon,
just look at the knee or I can't just look
at the hip because it's the result of all
of these interactions of the body.
That's what's so important.
Tim Ferriss: And in a case like mine where
if you look at family photos, especially on
my mom's side, the feet point way out.
A lot of the guys stand, they stand like ducks.
And now at the same time, I've been told,
and I agree with this, that if one were to
watch me walk, I have, probably because I
have at times the feet pointing out, very
little sort of glute hamstring assisted hip
extension.
So I tend to bend at that lower back.
Maybe I'm misdiagnosing things, but how would
you make sense of that?
Would it be bad for me to try to point my
feet a little more straight ahead so that
I get better hip extension using the gluteal
muscles in the hamstrings versus the lower
back?
Or is that going to be setting me up for knee
problems?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Usually if you're not
using your gluteal muscles and that it's because
you're swayed back.
If you’re swayed back, your line of gravity
is behind your hip joint.
If your line of gravity is behind your hip
joint, you don't need your gluteals, those
other muscles.
So if you reduce that kyphosis and get rid
of the, which isn't bad, it's just not helpful
for what your condition is.
And then you go forward.
And then the other thing is if you also push
off, in other words, when you're walking,
and this could be another way in which you're
reinforcing what your tensor is doing.
If you tend to walk by pulling your leg through
rather than pushing with your feet and letting
it swing through, and if you push with your
feet, you'll activate the extensors more.
So the two things, the things that may be
contributing to your — and I'm not saying
this is for sure because I'm obviously not
analyzing you.
But let's say if we paint a scenario that
you're swayed back with a kyphosis, your line
of gravity is behind your hip joint, then
the gluteals do not have good definition.
I call it missing for lack of action.
And so then you pull your legs forward with
your hip flexors.
You're just reinforcing the overuse of the
tensor.
But if you decrease your kyphosis, so your
line of gravity is a little more running through
your hip rather than way behind it, and you
roll over your feet and you push with your
feet.
Do you know what I'm saying?
So you roll over so that you're pushing with
the ball of your foot and your leg swings
out, you'll use your gluteals more.
Just pushing instead of pulling.
Tim Ferriss: Makes perfect sense.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: You want to chase your
center of gravity, not pull it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, this kyphosis has been
with me since I was a little kid.
I've tried foam rolling, manual release, strengthening
the mid-back.
But I have not worked on rectus abdominis.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: If you were little — there's
a condition called Scheuermann's disease,
which isn't really a disease.
But if you had it, particularly it happens
in your teenage years where you get a — you've
heard of it.
Tim Ferriss: No, I haven't heard of Scheuermann's
disease.
But ever since, I would say since I've been
12, 13, I've had this kyphosis lordosis combo.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well then you've probably
got Scheuermann's disease.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
I'll have to look it up.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: It's S-C-H-E-U-E-R-M-A-N-N.
And it's kind of a idiopathic compression
fracture of the thoracic spine.
It means you won't get rid of it.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, man.
Okay.
Well, can I do something to —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: But I think if you just
don't sway back more.
You know what I mean?
Just stay forward a little bit.
If you can make peace with that.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I can try to work on the
elongating of the —
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, it's just not
going to change.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: The big thing is don't
let it get worse.
Tim Ferriss: If I have it, yeah.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: If that's what you have.
Tim Ferriss: So what are the main steps to
—
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I'm not saying that's
what you have, but I'm saying.
But if you —
Tim Ferriss: It's possible.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Yeah, because it happens
around the teenage years.
Tim Ferriss: So what would be the keys to
not letting it get worse, would you say?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Don't have an increase.
You can still do the same things, Tim, but
just don't say "I will be absolutely perfect.
I have to settle for kind-of-perfect instead
of absolute perfect."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's probably a good
MO for most of my life, I would say.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, most of us don't
get that close.
There we go.
Tim Ferriss: Probably further away than I
would like to admit.
So Shirley, this has been such a great conversation.
We've covered so much.
I've taken copious, copious notes.
And certainly people can find your books,
the Diagnosis and Treatment of Movement Impairment
Syndromes, which has been translated into
seven languages, as well as your second book,
Movement System Impairment Syndromes of the
Extremities, Cervical and Thoracic Spines,
has been very influential in promoting movement
diagnoses.
Is there anything else you would like to mention?
Anything else we should talk about?
Anything you would like to draw attention
to with my audience?
Anything at all that you think is worth saying
or discussing before we begin to wind to a
close?
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Well, it's probably
just a little repeat of all the things we've
been talking about.
It's been really great and generous of you
to allow me to discuss your issues.
But what's really nice is here you are, somebody
that's worked so hard to address all of these
things with all the discipline that most people
don't have.
And it's still hard to get a straightforward
story about what's going on and how best to
suture.
And that's what worries me a lot is, number
one, is I look on the internet for exercises
and most of them people can't do.
And they're not taking into account the variations
in how people are.
Here you've been through all this exam and
nobody said you have femoral retroversion,
which you need to know because you came that
way.
You need to stay that way.
So I would like to see that there's more respect
for how difficult exercise is.
It's not like here's the way everybody should
go out and do this one thing and then all
will be well.
I'd like to see this recognition of that movement
is as complicated as anything else that the
body does, that there is a movement system,
a physiological thing.
And that we should have diagnostic categories
so that people, when they're consulting a
physical therapist, get a diagnosis just like
when they go to any doctor.
That's, to me, why you go to a doctor is to
get a diagnosis or find out what condition
you're working on.
And I think that would do a lot to help reducing
all this variability in treatment.
And I think helping people to understand how
it's the way they do their everyday activities
that causes the problem and that those can
be changed with good direction.
I can't help but say this too.
I help a good friend who's actually on a dementia
floor.
I go to help feed her twice a day.
And I look at all the other people, older
people that are in assisted living, and the
majority of them are there because they have
physical disabilities.
I'm older than most of them.
And I think if people had a chance to address
these things early on with the discipline
like you show and good direction, we could
cut down on and improve the quality of life.
I know you've interviewed Dr. Attia and much
of what he says, Medicine 3.0 or something,
and if we did that with more care on exercise
and knowing how to do everyday activities
and not just take them for granted, I think
people could have longer, fuller lives and
be as fortunate as I am.
Tim Ferriss: Agreed.
Agreed, agreed.
What a great conversation.
I've learned so much and I've taken so many
notes.
I have a lot to dig into.
It's also given me some renewed optimism in
terms of exercises that I can work with, movements
I should say that I can experiment with.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: I hope you'll get back
to me if I can help further.
If I find out that these things are going
along, I would be more than happy to.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: Just a little more formally.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely.
I appreciate it.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: We can do it on this.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I would very much like
to do that.
So thank you for the very kind offer and thank
you for so kindly taking the time to have
this conversation.
I think it'll be really helpful to people.
Dr. Shirley Sahrmann: As my dear friend Michael
said, you are tremendous.
I've really enjoyed talking to you, and you
do have a sense of enthusiasm on how to ask
the right questions, to make it fun for both
of us.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
And for everybody listening, we will link
in the show notes to everything we discussed
as usual at tim.blog/podcast.
And until next time, be just a bit kinder
than is necessary, not only to others, but
also to yourself.
And as always, thanks for tuning in.